here's a story you probably haven't
heard about has not gotten much if any
national press it's just a local story
from a small town in Maine
a 26 year old Public School social
worker at Great Salt Bay Community
School in Damariscotta Maine has been
secretly grooming a 13 year old girl
into believing that she's a boy without
telling her parents the girl's mother
Amber Levine only found out about the
psychosexual grooming after she
discovered a chest binder in her
daughter's bedroom a few weeks ago at
which point according to news reports
the daughter told her that she had
received the transgender fetish device
from a school staffer Named Sam Roy
according to the girl's mother School
Employees had started using male
pronouns to refer to the 13 year old
girl and Roy told the young girl to keep
the transition a secret from her parents
as Amber Levine rightly observed quote
this is the very definition of child
predatory sexual grooming Predators work
to gain a victim's trust by driving a
wedge between them and their parents
you probably hadn't heard about this
story for a couple of reasons
one the liberal media obviously want to
suppress it we all know that the media
say that this sort of thing isn't
happening and then when it's uncovered
they say it's good that it is happening
but the other reason that you probably
had not heard about this story the other
reason that this story is not front page
news as most normal people naturally
think that it should be
is that the story is becoming
commonplace
it just isn't all that newsy because it
keeps happening and it's not just
happening in Crazy liberal cities like
San Francisco and New York it's
happening everywhere
it's happening all over small town USA
and it is coming to a school near you if
it isn't there already I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Majesty who
says Korean Jean-Pierre should start
spelling her first name as Karine
c-a-r-e-e-n since she Koreans all over
the place in her non-answers to every
single question she's the biggest
purveyor of non-information to ever hold
that position I love that actually made
me made me laugh out loud I really like
that it is it is like a Norm Macdonald
joke yeah yeah you hear about this
Kareem Jean-Pierre yeah she should spell
her name Karine on account of she
Koreans everywhere
but it's true it's very it's funny
because it's true we got to protect
ourselves from these people who don't
want to give us correct information we
got to protect ourselves from these
people who want to deceive us we got to
protect ourselves from people who want
to break into our homes that's why you
got to check out ring with Christmas
right around the corner many people will
be traveling to see our families and
loved ones very very soon you may find
yourself away from home more often than
not that is why I've decided to team up
with ring with ring security products
you can rest easy knowing that your home
and family are safe when you're not
there the ring it doorbell notifies you
when guests or packages arrive Rings
indoor cameras let you keep an eye on
kids and pets while you are away ring
alarm will alert you of any motion
detection while the house is empty plus
if you add smart lighting around your
home you can turn lights on or off while
you are away Rings home security
products do not just help keep your home
and family safe they make perfect gifts
for everyone on your list as well I have
not only gotten ring I have also given
ring to my friends because I want them
to be safe okay head on over to ring.com
collections slash offers to find out how
you can live a little less stressed this
season with a ring product that is right
for you that is ring.com
collections slash offers I have to also
look I'm a man of my word I'm nothing if
not a man of my word all right
and I lost a bet to the crane and
Company guys
I guess to all the hosts actually and I
said I would wear a puka shell necklace
if I I don't even remember really the
terms of this bet anymore but anyway
here's my Puka shell necklace I'm gonna
look like a like a really cool Surfer
girl from the 90s now that's that's
great I actually think it looks kind of
nice maybe I'll wear it even after this
so it's certainly fitting with the topic
because we're talking about gender
transitions the story in Maine
is uh
shocking in how not shocking it is
because we've heard this story before
but but then you hear it in all these
little schools this isn't some school in
the middle of San Fran or LA or New York
or Washington DC or something it's in
the middle of nowhere Maine and it's
happening it's happening secretly and
it's happening all over the place it's
happening in Indiana there's just an
email that was uncovered uh it I think
it was uncovered by the Heritage
Foundation by the daily signal an
Indiana school
is forcing staff to hide gender
transition plans from parents this is an
email it's dated August 16th sent by a
counselor at Pendleton Heights High
School in Pendleton Indiana informing
teachers that a student had changed
genders now of course this is not
possible to change genders but that's
what the counselor said the boy is going
to be a girl or the girl's going to be a
boy in this case it's a girl pretending
to be a boy and the counselor affirms
this provides new male pronouns and says
that teachers should not inform the
student's parents because they were
quote not supportive of the decision
now it's it's a very interesting
observation
because the teacher or the counselor is
saying don't tell the parents what has
happened because the parents don't
support it how do you know the parents
don't support it if you won't tell them
you can't the the very fact of informing
someone or not informing someone should
should determine that but it's not
they're just assuming the family is not
supportive of this and so we're we're
just going to do it anyway two two
really thing two really big facts here
the school is
sexually grooming this child
and and then the school is saying when
there's a disagreement between this us
the liberal Educators and the parents
the liberal Educators went out
Indiana middle to Nowhere Indiana middle
of nowhere made it this is happening
in your town or it's happening in a town
near you I can almost guarantee it and
do you know who started this entire
trend
this is almost out of a movie
one of the main people behind this now
national school policy to hide gender
transitions of little kids from parents
was the bald-headed lipstick wearing
stiletto having luggage stealing nuclear
waste official from the Biden
Administration Sam Brinton who If This
Were a cartoon If This Were a comic book
which increasingly our country seems to
be this guy would be one of the big
super villains
he looks like it he acts like it and
this guy was behind the policy that now
instructs schools to keep this sexual
grooming from parents because before Sam
Brinton worked in the Biden
Administration he worked for a terrible
group called The Trevor Project
now the Trevor Project seems like it has
a really good Mission the Trevor Project
part of its Mission it says is to
prevent LGBT youths from killing
themselves so that's that's a worthwhile
Endeavor we don't want LGBT youths or
any other youths to kill themselves and
so that's a great thing but in practice
that's not what the Trevor Project does
in practice what the Trevor Project does
is works over time to indoctrinate kids
into
radical LGBT ideology Works to promote
transgenderism for every younger groups
of people we're talking about major
mutilations
disfigurements that will last a whole
lifetime that could sterilize kids all
it does is work to do all it works to do
rather is to double down on this crazy
ideology and so when Brenton was working
for the Trevor Project in 2019
he was directing advocacy and government
Affairs there he helped create a model
for school district policy for suicide
prevention
and the model has been adopted at least
partially by State education departments
in Arizona Idaho as well as local school
districts in California New Hampshire
Oregon other States including Washington
and New Jersey have similar policies and
and the the
model is don't tell parents when their
kids start getting into the weird sex
stuff
that's the model
and it's hard even to talk about it
because they say well we're doing this
to prevent suicides and it reminds me of
every abusive relationship you've ever
heard of
and man woman doesn't matter every
abusive relationship when it gets really
really bad they say if you don't do
exactly what I want I'm gonna kill
myself
and and it's this kind of emotional
blackmail and exploitation and
manipulation where even that people made
of the toughest stuff will very often
give in he says well I don't I don't
want that to happen and what the Trevor
Project does here what Sam Brinton does
here is even worse is they're saying if
you don't give us exactly what we want
your kid is going to kill himself
and what do we want we want you to pump
your kid full of hormones put your kid
on puberty blockers eventually chop off
your kids genitals and pretend that your
little son is actually your little
daughter or your little daughter is
actually your little son and if you
don't do that your kid is going to kill
himself that's what they're saying evil
evil stuff and not true by the way not
backed up by any evidence whatsoever
no evidence that the gender transition
and the various mutilations that go
along with it actually reduce suicide
rates among people who suffer this
sexual and gender confusion zero
evidence there's a lot of evidence that
people come to regret their transitions
even though the number of people who
have ever gone through these procedures
is extraordinarily small it's growing
very quickly and so now we're finally
starting to see the first round of
people who are beginning to regret this
and they're coming out they're saying
I've destroyed my body I've ruined my
voice I've ruined my hair I'm sterile
how on Earth could adults have allowed a
14 year old to do this sort of thing
we're finally hearing that the Trevor
Project Sam Brenton these school
districts in Indiana and Maine all over
the country they say no forget about
that ignore that
if you don't engage in
the radical insane ideology to mutilate
and castrate your kids well they are
just going to kill themselves and you're
gonna have that blood on your hands can
you imagine
why does Sam Brinton care so much about
your kids why do all these people
they're all the same they're you know
there are all these weirdo guidance
counselors like the guy up in May and
the 26 year I think he's a guy who knows
he goes by Sam which I guess is gender
ambiguous
but who knows I guess he presents as a
guy so let's call him a guy
why is he so interested in a 13 year old
girl and psychosexually grooming her why
is Sam Brenton I think a large part of
the reason why these people are so
focused on your kids and driving a wedge
between you and your kids and perverting
the mind and body of your kids is in is
in large part because they don't have
kids themselves
I'm not saying they would abuse their
children or sexually abuse their
children or anything like that I'm
saying
when people have children they raise
their children in the way that they want
them to be raised if you're a Christian
family you're going to raise your kids
to be Christian if you're a Jewish
Family you're going to raise your kids
to be Jewish if you're a weird lib
you're going to raise your kids you're
going to at least try to raise your kids
to be a weird lib
but these people don't have kids and so
I think they're I strongly suspect
they're natural longings to form the
next generation are just being projected
onto your kids where there is so much
less accountability where they are so
much more willing to engage in radical
kind of behaviors because they won't
have to deal with any of the
consequences
not good stuff we got to get back to
basics we got to get back to the truth
when you want to do that you got to
check out Bible and ear with father Mike
Schmitz right now head on over to
ascensionpress.com Knowles if you are
someone who has always wanted to read
and understand the Bible but you're not
sure where to start you've got to check
out the Bible in a year podcast from
Ascension the Bible in a year podcast is
currently the most popular religion
podcast in the United States millions of
people have listened to it and twice
it's hit the number one spot on Apple
podcasts which is just such a great
white pill that is in all this crazy
culture the fact that Bible in a year
with father Mike Schmidt's hit number
one twice actually makes you think
there's some hope for the culture in the
podcast father Mike Schmitz reads the
entire Bible in 365 daily episodes
providing helpful commentary reflection
and prayer along the way what better way
to start the new year it is my favorite
podcast it's the only podcast that I
reliably listen to in my car I'm
surrounded by podcasts all day okay
that's the one that I really go to and
if you you get a little busy and you
miss it it can become Bible in two years
okay it's not going anywhere it is a
great great podcast you get it for free
on your favorite podcast app or YouTube
if you want to start reading and more
importantly understanding the Bible this
year go to ascensionpress.com Knowles to
download the reading plans for free
that's ascensionpress.com Knowles to
download the reading plan for free
there's another big consequence of
people not having kids
beyond the insane transformation of our
education system
this might be the saddest story
that I have read in a while
and I'm reading stories about these
creepy adults mutilating children so
it's a that's a lot to say this might be
the saddest story
the toy industry
has only one main area of growth in
recent years
and that main area of growth
is adults
the toy kids are not buying more and
more toys
adults are they call them kidults
buying toys for themselves is the
biggest source of growth for the
industry kidults
have a great fondness for cartoons Star
Wars and Lego in recent years toy makers
such as Mattel have created Lines Just
for these consumers these kids at heart
are responsible for one quarter of all
toy sales annually
stop
I'm preaching to the choir here because
I strongly suspect the kind of people
who listen to this show are not the kind
of adults who issue all of their
responsibilities and regress into living
you know and moving into their childhood
bedrooms and playing with little toys
all day long while their mother makes
them cookies and brings them milk I
assume
I think I I have good reason to believe
that the people listening to this show
tend to be a little more responsible and
mature no so I'm preaching to the choir
but
if you know someone if you know
an adult
who's buying a lot of toys
tell them to stop
it cut it out
I go back to this advice all the time on
the show Don Corleone sitting there with
Johnny Fontaine shakes and he says
You're Gonna Act Like a Man
what's the matter with you what is a
matter with you
I've seen this happen the reason I know
this isn't just made up I mean I'm we're
seeing data from the NPD group it's
being being reported in other major
Outlets
but the reason I know it's happening is
friends of mine have done this
friends of mine they'll get really into
Legos or something or they'll get really
into playing with some toy or even
stuffed animals or even they
and why is that it's because they're
nostalgic and Nostalgia is a Temptation
it's a Temptation we should resist
because Nostalgia is history after a few
drinks and those Halcyon Days were not
quite as great as you remember them
being and even if they were you can't go
to the past and while it is perfectly
appropriate for a five-year-old to play
with little toys it is not appropriate
for a 25 year old to play with little
toys just as it is totally normal for
for someone in their mid-20s to spend a
lot of time bar hopping you know going
out every night of the weekend hitting
up a bunch of bars and dance
clubs and disc attacks I don't know I
sound like such a boomer going down to
the old dance hall and playing
more for people in their 20s
it's less normal for people in their 50s
to be doing that sort of thing there is
a time to every season under Heaven okay
a time for war and Time For Peace a time
for playing with little toys a time for
not playing with little toys and the the
millennial generation I'm sorry to say
it's my own generation they don't want
to grow up they're delaying marriage
they're delaying moving out of their
parents house they're delaying getting
jobs they're delaying having kids
they're delaying everything they're
stuck as overgrown children and they
they really should stop that okay it's
not cute
it's not you playing with your little
toys it's not cute McDonald's just came
out and and offered a kid's meal for
adults playing on this very problem of
Perpetual adolescence among people who
are way too old for that now
okay
stop it the thing is when when you're an
adult you're bogged down and you know
you've got maybe tough relationships and
you got your job that you're slogging
through and so yes you do need an outlet
for recreation and Leisure that's true
now one hopes that you can cultivate
interests that are more appropriate to
your age group so I buy plenty of toys
right I but the toys that I buy are
little musical instruments so yeah the
things little kids can play with but
it's not I'm not you know I'm not buying
like little plush Star Wars figures or
something like that okay it's that's I
buy plenty I buy cigars that's a toy for
adults I buy whiskey that's a toy for
adults okay that I'm not saying you
can't have your fun activities and by
the way sometimes you you do you have
this Drive of nostalgia and you you want
to play with a little toy you want to
get down to play with a train set or
something like that you can do that as
an adult
with your children okay it's fun to play
with your children even me I'm pretty
stodgy it's I like getting down on the
ground and playing with the little
blocks or whatever with my kids and that
is that is the properly ordered way to
channel that natural
nostalgic yearning for the innocence and
joys of Youth but if you take the kid
out of that and if it's just you you
know a 30-something sitting there in
your gym jams playing with a train track
that is sad don't do that okay goodness
great you're just you're it's like
something that the libs always do which
is they want the
image of the thing they want the facade
of the thing but they don't want the
essence of the thing I'm speaking a
little abstractly so I'll drive it home
libs are the kind of people who love
decaf coffee
okay libs are the kind of people who
love transvestitism they love the sort
of exterior uh
outward symptoms of a thing but they
don't want the essence of it and so it's
yes it's fun to play around when you're
an adult
but the essence of playing around when
you're an adult is doing it with your
child to entertain your child to form a
close relationship and to educate that
child when you're just doing it for
yourself it's just sad
and the
The Late Late stage capitalists are
profiting off of you and encouraging you
to do it because
the thing is I don't mean to
harp too much on the selfishness of my
millennial
cohort because there are a lot of social
factors that are pushing this
I even intentionally use this language
of the commies when they're always
whining about late stage capitalism
because that is a little bit of a
problem too it's not just the big
government that is pushing people to
into these culturally degrading
behaviors it's also Private Industry
it's also entertainment it's also social
media it's all of that is working right
now there was a piece just in NBC
well actually the piece appeared five
years ago it just is circulating again
because it was referenced in a
Washington Post column that also has
been circulating very recently which is
that science proves kids are bad for the
Earth morality suggests we stop having
them we need to stop having kids because
it's it's bad for the environment as
ethical consequences this is written by
someone who pretends to be a bioethicist
this is someone named Travis reader and
what what does he say
so several years ago the giant
scientists showed that having a child
especially for the world's wealthy is
one of the worst things you can do for
the environment
that that statement is essentially a
meaningless statement by the way but he
said it's just scientists prove it so if
they're saying they have lab coats that
obviously it's true having a child
imposes High Emissions on the world
while the parents get the benefit so
like with any high cost luxury we should
limit our Indulgence of children
then he goes this is an amazing analogy
he says if I release a murderer from
prison knowing full well that he intends
to kill innocent people then I bear some
responsibility for those deaths even
though the Killer is also fully
responsible by having released him
doesn't make him less responsible he did
it but his doing it doesn't eliminate my
responsibility either some something
similar is true I think when it comes to
having children once my daughter is an
autonomous agent she'll be responsible
for her emissions but that doesn't
negate any responsibility moral
responsibility simply isn't mathematical
okay so he's comparing having kids with
murdering people
and this is a telling analogy because
this is what all these guys think they
think that human beings are a disease
and that's why they encourage us to not
have kids and you're having the
government encourage you to not have
kids and you're having the
non-government non-profit organizations
encouraging you and I have kids and
you're having the for-profit
corporations encouraging you to not have
kids you're getting taxpayer subsidized
abortion and contraception you are
getting ngos going all around the world
and in our own country pushing abortion
pushing contraception pushing Family
Planning and Planned Parenthood but
you're getting the corporations doing it
too corporations paying for people to
get abortions why because it's not just
the evil big government and it's not
just the awful terrible activists who
are professional agitators it's it's the
capitalists too recognize that you know
if those moms are staying home raising
their families that's not going to be
great for weight that's going to raise
wages it's going to raise the cost of
Labor that if the women do happen to
work you're going to have to give them
maternity leave that's going to be very
very expensive it'd be a lot cheaper
just to convince the mother to not have
children in the first place to not get
married so you don't even have the
possibility of of children you know a
man and a woman in a Perpetual Union for
the good good of the spouses and the
sake of the generation and education of
children or if they do get pregnant just
encourage that woman to to kill her baby
there are there are incentives at every
stage of the government to do this sort
of thing and what I I feel so sorry for
so many of my
millennial
friends and cohort and people who are
younger as well because they're being
duped they're being tricked into this by
so many of the lies of our culture I was
just talking about this with my cousin
yesterday I got to see my cousin and he
said man you know what it's it's only in
recent years I've really been thinking
about it I realized going out all the
time is not totally fulfilling
but but that's what the culture is
telling us to do go out don't get
married dump your girlfriend dump your
boyfriend move to the city have casual
sex all the time don't have any
attachments don't have any kids it's
selfish it's bad for the environment
it's bad for the company it's bad for
the country it's bad for the
entitlements it's bad for them blah blah
blah blah blah it's always the same
thing and and it goes right back to the
first lie in the Garden of Eden okay it
goes right back to the principalize
himself and it's the marker of the devil
I'm not speaking hyperbolically here
when you have movements that hate people
that want fewer people that want to kill
people that want to limit the number of
people that don't want people to be born
in the first place that is the marker of
the devil and you should be aware and
you should not be duped speaking of our
crazy chaotic culture right now
if you want to protect some of your
assets when the stock market's going all
over the place you should go check out
Birch gold right now text nulls to 98 98
98 will the lack of a red wave during
the midterm elections lead to more
Reckless spending by an emboldened
Administration higher taxes deeper
inflation
all of the above probably if you are not
sure how the next two years will unfold
or even worse if you are sure how the
next two years will unfold talk to Birch
gold group about protecting your savings
with gold Birch gold makes it easy to
convert your IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals so you can own gold and
silver in a tax sheltered account gold
is the world's oldest most proven form
of currency when inflation soars and all
other assets go sideways gold is still
there this month you can get a free gold
back with every five thousand dollar
purchase I love these Gold bags they're
extremely cool when you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into a precious
metals Ira with Birch gold by December
22nd that's coming up just text Knowles
kwles to 98 9898 Birch gold will help
you own gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account text Knowles to 98 98
98 to claim your free info kit on gold
then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists with every purchase
you make before December 22nd you will
get a free gold back great stocking
stuff for just in time for Christmas
text Knowles Kennedy Les to 98 98 98 and
protect yourself with gold today
another big consequence of depopulation
or of stagnant populations where
populations not growing actually in the
United States we have a dying population
one of the consequences is mass
migration
which the government loves
and which Private Industry loves
a big government liberal Democrats they
love Mass migration
is mass migration they believe and I
think they have good reason to believe
gives them a permanent electoral
Advantage because immigrants the kind of
immigrants that the Democrats are
importing right now from Latin America
with few exceptions the Cubans would
maybe be an exception but with few
exceptions they vote Democrat their kids
vote Democrat their grandkids vote
Democrat there's a big movement of a lot
of them over to the Republicans right
now but it still favors the Dems
so that's why the government likes it
Private Industry which has more
representation for conservatives and
Republicans they also love Mass
migration the reason they love Mass
migration is because it provides a cheap
Workforce and it keeps wages low
and allows businesses to increase their
profit margins so you've got this this
effort right now from both sides of the
political aisle in the United States to
encourage Americans not to have more
children and to import in order to keep
up the entitlement state
in order to keep industry going you then
import cheaper workers from the third
world and that's what's happening
according to Customs and Border
Protection uh tens of thousands of
migrants
are headed to the U.S border right now
this happens every so often
where you'll see some huge migrant
Caravan from working its way up through
Latin America these events shouldn't be
all that shocking in that we have two
million illegal aliens come every single
year with thousands of thousands of
people every single day across our
border but when you see these incidents
where it's thirty thousand forty
thousand uh CBP agents are now
predicting more than 40 000 migrants in
southern Mexico who will soon be at the
U.S border when you see that it's
shocking because you can at least look
at the pictures but you're getting a
tenth of that every day in the United
States so it's not it
it's only shocking in that it allows us
to see what is persistently happening in
the country
what is this this is not just politics
this is not just an issue okay where you
talk about abortion as an issue very
serious issue but it's an issue taxes
that's an issue
the the war in Iraq are we still
fighting that one and I think we wrapped
that one up the war in Ukraine the war
wherever that's an issue
immigration this kind of mass migration
is not a regular political issue it is a
metapolitical issue
it's the politics of politics
it's the politics of how the Democrats
are going to win at politics
because by flooding the country with
illegal aliens and with legal immigrants
to Legal immigrants also overwhelmingly
vote for Democrats so you've got two
million illegal immigrants 1 million
legal immigrants coming in every single
year this represents the largest
movement of human beings in recorded
history
and that's into the United States over
the past 60 years you were seeing the
Democrats transform the demography of
the country to favor them
that's why they're doing it
it's not because they have any
particular love for Guatemalan peasants
okay they don't
but they they do have love for winning
elections and so you're seeing this
meta-political change and the
Republicans
largely fail to address it there's one
exception here and this is some good
news
the Supreme Court
led by Chief Justice Roberts who is
usually a big squish
has just temporarily halted the entrance
of this migrant Caravan into the United
States and the way he did it
was by granting an 11th Hour request by
more than a dozen GOP controlled states
to temporarily pause a lower Court
ruling that had ordered the end of a
covid era protection known as title 42.
so all a very complicated
political issue title 42 was was used by
the Trump Administration it's a public
health law to allow U.S border officials
to expel illegal aliens even if the
illegal aliens want to apply for
political Asylum and usually they're not
really political Asylum cases usually
they're just economic migrants looking
to make some money but many will pretend
to be seeking political Asylum
and this then triggers a process where
it's much more difficult to expel them
from the country well title 42 says look
we're in a pandemic
covid you all know covid is so dangerous
it's the most dangerous virus we've ever
seen in the whole wide world and so
because of that
we're now going to use this public
health law
to expel the illegal aliens talk about
making lemonade out of lemons talk about
a silver lining in a storm cloud so
Trump
used this mechanism
very wisely that was a very very smart
move by Trump Biden's been trying to
undo it but it's not so easy it's just
undoing it and snapping your fingers you
have to take this through the courts and
the Supreme Court has just said no we're
going to leave it in place
for now and so the Democrats are stymied
in their plans to flood the country
with the illegal aliens
what we should learn from the use of
title 42.
and from this great at least temporary
decision from the Supreme Court is one
elections really do matter
we we sometimes get depressed we say the
elections don't matter they rig the
votes they don't but elections really do
matter
Roe v Wade was determined by elections
the ending of Roe v Wade was determined
by Republicans just barely eeking
through their president getting their
judges on Accord just in the right
amount of time and then this court
making important decisions even Roberts
who is who's a squishy judge
having him on the court just gave us
the the halting of this migrant Caravan
at the border
but the the more important lesson I
think to learn is
conservatives should use
Democrat Ops and hoaxes and
political dirty tricks
against them
the Democrats are always going to be
playing their dirty tricks the Democrats
are always going to say oh there's a
virus from China
we need to shut down all the churches
shut down the businesses we need to we
need to transfer wealth from small
businesses to large corporations that
are in our pockets or in whose Pockets
we are sometimes it gets a little bit
blurry and we need to we need to do all
we need to force you to take this shot
we need to change education we need to
change everything we need a great reset
we're going to do every single thing
that we wanted to do for 100 years yeah
all because of the virus right total
dirty trick total totally total
political operation
but
like any good chess player like any good
any good athlete when you when you see
your light you got to take it and so
Trump saw the light on that and he said
okay
we've got this terrible virus and you're
gonna say it's the worst thing ever okay
good then we're gonna we're gonna have
to use title 42. because if it's so
terrible it's such a terrible virus then
we can't let these tens of thousands of
migrants come in right and then we're
gonna say wait wait wait no I don't know
about that I said hold on what are you
talking about you're telling me that an
adult American
totally healthy
at no risk whatsoever really from this
virus is not allowed to go shopping
if he doesn't have three booster shots
of the experimental drug but but a
Nicaraguan peasant coming through with
no inoculation whatsoever he can just
come right into the country Waltzing and
it's no big deal what are you talking
about I have to get a covid test every
time I want to walk into a hospital to
see a sick relative I'm usually I'm not
even allowed into those hospitals we're
not allowed to bury our own dead this is
so dangerous we have to quarantine but
you're telling me that that uh
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of Latin American migrants can just walk
right on through no big deal we're not
going to take the temperature
come on that's ridiculous well
they got us there and we've used that
we've we have been able to stop
some illegal immigration now it's not
enough
but it's just a reminder for those
conservatives who say well if we
if we ever
do the sorts of things that the libs do
the libs use these mechanisms and they
use it for Injustice and immorality and
to make our country worse if we ever use
these kinds of legal and political
mechanisms to make our country better
well that would make us no different
from the Liberals no it would make you
very different because good and bad are
opposites they're different and they're
opposites
making the country better and making the
country worse are not the same thing
well in both cases you're using the
power of the state and you're you're
using one of these laws and you're
having the judges come in yeah right
it's called politics it's called
politics
and it's good to use politics for good
things
it's bad to use politics for bad things
and it's not hypocritical when you do
good things and you don't want to do bad
things okay it's not not hypocritical at
all this was the topic of my speech
yesterday at America Fest an amazing
amazing event as always nobody throws a
show and to party and a political event
like Charlie Kirk and TP USA Nobody Does
it it's just amazing there were I think
12
000 attendees
at America Fest in Phoenix yesterday
just in the one big room I think there
was something like 8 000 chairs and
there were so many other events
simultaneously happening it was just
amazing you can catch my speech on the
tpusa YouTube page
but it really gives you hope
you show up you think okay these These
are pretty clever fired up people maybe
there's a way to break the Democrat the
liberal hegemony
I'll give you a great example
of a liberal ridiculous op
the January 6th committee is now
referring Donald Trump to the Department
of Justice
for criminal Insurrection charges
now this is a committee made up only of
Democrats
nominal Democrats and
de facto Democrats
they're urging the doj to consider
charging Trump with inciting or aiding
an Insurrection Democrat rep Jamie
Raskin announced this referral he
described it as quote
a grave federal offense anchored in the
Constitution itself and then he noted
this was automatic grounds for
disqualifying some from holding state or
federal office
these people they don't give up they
don't give up they don't
2015 we say Donald Trump you can't run
for office he slept with models and porn
stars you know that thing that we've all
known about him for decades you know the
thing that um
a pretty prominent recent Democrat
president did very publicly and
scandalously yeah so Trump he's
disqualified and then what he colluded
with the Russians he's disqualified and
then he colluded with the ukrainians
even though the ukrainians hate the
Russians and the Russians anyway they he
colluded with both somehow and he's
disqualified and he's an instructionist
and even though no one involved in the
Capitol Hill Riot has been charged with
Insurrection at all because it's just
ridiculous uh he he's he can't run now
and he's a total loser and everyone
hates him and there's no way he could
ever win and that's why we have to do
everything we can to prevent him from
appearing on the ballot that doesn't
quite add up to me
what should the GOP take from this
well the GOP can mock it I think it's
good to mock the jacket but John you
worry six commission it's very funny to
mock that and it's good to do that the
GOP can ignore it okay that's fine the
GOP can get angry about it that I don't
I don't know why I I wouldn't get angry
it's such a joke I mean doj is probably
going to pick it up they've been all
going after Trump for seven years now
but
whatever you know I mean it's just not
these aren't serious people they don't
have principles there so there's no use
getting riled up about that what I think
the GOP should do
is
use these kinds of operations against
the Democrats I think I would humbly
propose especially as the GOP is about
to take control of the House of
Representatives saw some of my
Republican Congressman friends yesterday
at TP USA I would recommend as the GOP
is thinking about
investigating Hunter Biden okay that's
fine where the GOP is talking about
investigating Dr fauci yeah I think
that's good I think we should
investigate Dr fauci
I think the GOP should investigate and
potentially prosecute
Democrat politicians
for incitement against the GOP
for even potentially Insurrection I
think they should they should do exactly
to the Democrats what the Democrats are
trying to do to Republicans the
Republicans have far better grounds to
do it to the Democrats Democrats like
Maxine Waters have incited violence have
Paul explicitly called for violence
pushing back on people in public going
to Republican politicians homes
against the GOP against the conservance
Chuck Schumer said we're coming for you
Neil Gorsuch we're coming for you Brett
Kavanaugh and what happened liberal
takes a bus from California to
Washington D.C and tries to assassinate
Brett Kavanaugh drag Chuck Schumer
before that committee drag Maxine Waters
before that committee drag all these
Democrats drag Kamala Harris who bailed
out the rioters during BLM drag the
Biden Administration staffers who bailed
at the Riders the violent people during
BLM who encouraged the BLM rights drag
them accuse them of incitement to
violence accuse them of insurrection
accuse them of all the same stuff that
they're accusing us of make look I think
there's a much stronger case
that we have to make against the
Democrats on these grounds but even if
not even if it's all just a big joke
then make a bigger mockery of this than
the Democrats did
shove it in their face or what are we
going to do we're going to roll over
we're gonna investigate Hunter by and
we're gonna find all all sorts of
perverted things on the laptop none of
it's going to stick
Joe Biden is not going to be held to
account for anything
and then we're going to lose the house
at some point and then nothing happened
no
fight back against this nonsense show
them that you are not going to take this
lying down we are just days away
from Christmas
and you cannot hide from the truth any
longer
you still
don't have gifts for everyone on your
list I know it that's true of me too
okay we all know it
Jeremy's razors is here to help Jeremy's
e-gift cards are the perfect present for
all of those woke free folks that you
narrowly neglected
they are 100 guaranteed to arrive in
time for Christmas
that's right not even Joe Biden's supply
chain can prevent your friends and
family from unwrapping a great gift on
the big day and whether they opt for the
Precision 5 razor with flipback Tremor
tea tree oil and Argan Oil shampoo and
conditioner or even the luxurious beard
kit you and your gift card recipients
can take extra merriment knowing you
have helped make woke razor companies
that hate you even poorer
bring a gift not an excuse go to
dailywire.com Knowles to pick up your
Jeremy's razer's e-gift cards and put
the finishing touches on your Christmas
shopping
what matters in politics is winning
we want to win
in a just
moral legal way
but assuming all of those things we have
to win
we don't want to lose
we don't want to lose with dignity
as some of the squishes often want us to
do
there isn't usually very much dignity in
losing with dignity
you see this principle articulated by
Donald Trump and we now know this
because hope Hicks
was giving testimony to the genuine sex
commission and hope Hicks explained
her disagreements with and the advice
that she gave to and the response she
heard from president Trump
after the election
the select committee has obtained
testimony from new Witnesses who've come
forward to tell us about their
conversations with ex-president Trump on
this topic here is one of his senior
advisors hope Hicks
Ying
evidence of
fraud on a scale that would have
impacted the outcome of the election and
I was becoming increasingly concerned
that
we were damaging
um
we were damaging his legacy what did the
president say in response to what she
just described
he said something along the lines of
um
you know nobody will care about my
legacy if
I lose
um
so that won't matter the only thing that
matters is
is winning
putting any particulars aside about
Trump's Behavior after the 2020 election
I know some people think he fought like
hell and that was a great thing and some
people say no he didn't present proper
evidence of Fraud and so what he did was
irresponsible and it it hurt his chances
of running again okay whatever that's
not what I'm talking about right now
that we can have those disagreements
the principle that Trump is articulating
here
according to Hope Hicks who was a very
trusted advisor of his
is correct
what matters in politics
assuming we're all operating within the
bounds of justice and legality and
morality what matters is winning this is
a principle that was articulated best I
think by cocaine Mitch who love him or
hate him the man knows a lot about
winning the man is very very good at
wielding political power
and cocaine Mitch said in response to
one of his opponents he got Pablo
Escobar Mitch over here versus the DEA
of his opponents and he said
the winners go to Washington and make
laws and the losers go home
say hello
to my little friend
and that's what he said and the last
part I assume that's what he was
thinking
he's right about that
the winners make laws the losers go home
nobody is going to give Trump a pat on
the head and say well he look we called
him Hitler for four years well like five
or six years actually and
we fought him every step of the way and
we impeached him twice we just hate him
so much but he
he had a great legacy
one termers don't get great legacies
even if the liberal media pretend to
like them a little bit as a way to
attack whoever the presently dangerous
Republican is in the long run one
termers don't really get great legacies
okay what matters is winning and doing
and succeeding
Trump was totally right did it matter in
the end I don't know it remains to be
seen because he's running again in 2024.
now speaking of Trump's chances at
winning in 2024 new poll lab from USA
Today and Suffolk you
showing that
Rhonda Santos Trump's Chief GOP rival
right now
is currently leading Joe Biden in a
nationwide head-to-head poll
a DeSantis leads with 47 support
followed by Biden with 43 support
according to the poll 65 percent of
Republicans and GOP leaning voters want
DeSantis to run for president Trump does
not perform as well against Biden in
this particular survey Biden is leading
Trump by seven points
47 to 40 and the survey shows
Republicans prefer DeSantis over Trump
by 23 percent
this is good news for DeSantis this is
bad news for Trump
but it doesn't quite tell you what it
seems to be telling you because the the
assumptions in the poll
are unrealistic
we're talking about here a nationwide
head-to-head poll
but the election does not take place
Nationwide the election takes place in a
handful of states in a handful of
counties and what really separates the
election is not millions of votes or
dozens or even 100 electoral votes
though those numbers might look that way
in the end what actually determines the
winner is usually
and especially in recent years
20 000 votes in this state 40 000 votes
in this state 30 000 votes I mean it
could be sixty seventy thousand votes to
determine the entire election so it
doesn't really matter how many people in
California or New York like one
candidate over the other they're popular
states but it doesn't really matter what
matters is
what people in Georgia Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin Arizona
what matters is who they vote for
and what matters is who counts the votes
especially if we're talking about
Maricopa County in Arizona we're talking
about Philadelphia or we're talking
about
Atlanta in in Georgia that's what's
going to determine it okay and so this
is all great news for for DeSantis
DeSantis World should be celebrating
over this Trump should be genuinely
scared about it but it doesn't totally
mean also we don't know if if Biden will
be the Democrat nominee he says he's
going to be
but Democrats don't seem all that eager
for it he'll be 80 years old does
anybody really believe or he maybe I
think he he might already be eight I
think he was 78 when he took office so
he'll be 82
for a second term that seems that seems
pretty old to be doing that job
and we don't know what the GOP Primary
process looks like Trump has had
everything thrown at him Rhonda Sanders
has had a lot thrown at him too but
still not at the national level and then
there are other candidates who could
emerge as well
going to be quite a fight speaking of
voting before we go really a great story
out of Twitter
I haven't covered Twitter so every day
there's new Twitter news but at a
certain point you think okay all right
Twitter they'll sort it out it's a
social media site we all spend too much
time on it anyway
Elon Musk has just uh announced that in
the future as he makes policy by Twitter
poll by popular vote as Elon Musk has
been doing recently he is going to
limit the people who can vote to people
who actually subscribe to Twitter blue
that's the paid service on Twitter you
pay a few bucks a month maybe it's eight
bucks a month now and you will get
certain perks and then you'll get to
vote and have a stake in this
this is a great move well it's a great
move for Twitter
but it's also something that we can
learn from it's a civics lesson for all
of us
the people who vote and who determine
how our government our politics is going
to work should be people
who have some stake in the society
this is really basic stuff the founding
fathers the framers the Constitution all
wrote about this we've lost this idea in
recent years as we've made an idol out
of democracy as we've made an idol out
of the popular vote
is a good role for democracy there's
certain certainly can be in politics or
that can be a role for popular voting or
representational democracy aspects of
direct democracy there can be rules for
all this stuff but it's not the be-all
and end-all okay it's not an idol that
we should make and if you open up the
vote to everybody if you let
five-year-olds vote that's probably not
going to be very conducive to the
flourishing of your Republic so there
are always going to be limits here and
one of the limits that our Great Men Who
Built our country talked about that Elon
is recognizing here is the people who
determine how the government should be
run ought to be people who have a real
stake in things we've got real skin in
the game amazing that we're taking
political lessons from Twitter now but
it's because Twitter's new management is
a lot smarter than the old management
and maybe the management of our current
government now other really great news
uh people might be asking why I'm
wearing this a puka shell necklace
this is because I'm a man of my word
I don't Welsh on bets and we took a bet
before the midterms about different
Shenanigans in the bet I didn't
completely lose but I didn't totally win
and so as part of that I had to wear a
puka shell necklace and I kind of like
it actually I think it's I think
compliments me very very well uh certain
other hosts at the daily wire
are known to Welch on their bets and
some of their names actually sound a lot
like that word okay and some of their
first names are Matthew and some of them
sometimes when they lose football games
don't want to fulfill their obligations
and call me Sweet Daddy Knowles but I
have to give Matt credit where credit is
due
on the backstage show he did give me
this as my secret Santa it is a viewer
discretion advised very disturbing it's
a it's a picture of Sweet Daddy Knowles
with my little
sort of very luscious Sicilian lips on
this image nice quaffed hair there and
it says Sweet Daddy Knowles on there
this is not available in the merch shop
I believe this is the only uh t-shirt of
this kind that exists
and I'm glad that it exists at least
Walsh went halfway
toward fulfilling his obligations and
recognizing that I am a Sweet Sweet
Daddy the rest of the show continues now
today is not music Monday but we're
making it music Monday because you know
I'm a pop Maven we're I was on the road
yesterday it was a little tricky to do
the member block so uh Ben Davies says
that I am now going to complete the pop
music Trifecta we have done T Swift
we've done the Biebs
now we are moving on to Ed Sheeran if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]